[Musique]
Irish jig c'était l'ouverture du tout
premier album de Gwendal en 74 sur la
pochette de ce disque il y avait un
géant qui enjambait notre verte campagne
n'est-ce pas dans le sens peut-être
symbolique d'ailleurs de la ville vers
la campagne il jouait de la bombarde et
il allait peut-être dans cette campagne
se ressourcer comme on dit en tout cas
c'était la naissance d'un nouveau groupe
de folk breton Gwendal qui au début
n'allait pas faire tout à fait
l'unanimité pourquoi et bien parce que
l'image globale du groupe était breton
mais le disque était plus éclectique
plus diversifié autour des traditionnels
irlandais on pouvait entendre par
exemple une bourrée saintongoise une
bourrée au verniat et même un morceau du
Texas et puis au sacrilège ces gens
habitaient Paris voire parfois ils
jouaient même dans le métro enfin et
surtout il y avait des hardiesses quant
au traitement de la musique broton ces
hardiè elles allaient éclater
complètement dans le deuxème disque de
Gwendal faire l'origine du groupe mais à
cette époque aussi démultiplier la
polémique autour du groupe écoutez
plutôt
[Musique]
J
l'originalité de Gwendal se révélait
donc son truc sa ficelle si je puis dire
sa griffe en fait et bien prendre un
thème traditionnel après l'avoir exposé
et bien se livrer à des petits
développements Jaz comme celui qu'on
vient d'entendre ce deuxème album de sur
croix soit dit en passant pochette
dessinée par Claire bretcher confirmait
l'orientation définitive bretonne du
groupe en 77 sort le 3è disque du groupe
l'album de la maturité musicale et qui
confirme aussi le flirt du groupe avec
certains dessinateurs de la bande
dessinée la pochette est en effet
dessinée par le merveilleux Bilal qui
vient tout juste de sortir le vaisseau
de pierre encré chez nous en Bretagne en
80 4e album de Gwendal pochette dessinée
par picoto désormais le style de Gwendal
se reconnaî à mil sillons à la ronde
témoin le B new avec jeune mot bien sûr
qu'on va écouter maintenant c'est un
morceau du groupe on dirait un
traditionnel on pourrait presque danser
dessus et pourtant il est à 7 ans bref
un découpage rythmique que d'habitude on
rencontre dans le
[Musique]
jazz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a aussi sur ce 4e disque de Gwendal
un morceau qui à mon sens résume
complètement le groupe sa musique sa
démarche musicale par excellence
l'ouverture et puis son esprit l'humour
l'humour continuel il y a en effet un
réget Breton par définition le brassage
culturel dont parlait encore récemment à
l'instival à propos de sa symphonie
celtique donc un authentique gilet
breton une authentique chemise des îles
un peu de soleil beaucoup d'humour un
certain humour un grand éclat de rire
libérateur puis après on viendra à des
choses plus sérieuses Gwendal le rggay
de
[Musique]
Guéret
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]